- [Instructor] We are
told that triangle N'
is the image of triangle N
under a dilation.
So this is N' in this red color,
and then N is the original
N is in this blue color.
What is the center of dilation?
And they give us some
choices here, choice A,
B, C, or D as the center of dilation.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure it out
on your own.
So there's a couple of
ways to think about it.
One way I like to just first think about,
well what is the scale factor here?
So in our original N,
we have this side here,
it has a length of two,
and then once we dilated it by,
and used that scale factor,
the corresponding side
has a length of four.
So we went from two to four.
So we can figure out our scale factor,
scale factor is equal to two.
Two times two is equal to four.
Now what about our center of dilation?
So one way to think about it is,
pick two corresponding points.
So let's say we were to pick this point
and this point.
So the image,
the corresponding point on N',
is going to be the scale factor
as far away from our center of dilation
as the original point.
So in this example we know
the scale factor is two,
so this is going to be twice as far
from our center of dilation
as the corresponding point.
Well you can immediately see,
and it's going to be
in the same direction,
so actually if you just draw
a line connecting these two,
there's actually only one
choice that sits on that line,
and that is choice D right over here
as being the center of dilation.
And you can also verify that notice,
this first point on the original triangle,
its change in x is two and
its change in y is three,
two three, to go from
from point D to point
to that point.
And then if you wanna go
to point D to its image,
well now you gotta go twice as far.
Your change in x is four,
and your change in y is six.
You could use the Pythagorean Theorem
to calculate this distance
and then the longer distance,
but what you see is,
is that the corresponding
point is now twice as far
from your center of dilation.
So there's a couple of
ways to think about it.
One, if you connect corresponding points,
your center of dilation
is going to be on a line
that connects those two points.
And that the image should
be the scale factor
as far away from the center of dilation,
in this case it should be twice as far
from the center of dilation as the point
that it is the image of.